une coalition de l'irresponsabilité à
envoyer l'image d'un pays
qui est incapable de se fixer comme
objectif de maîtriser sa dépense
publique la nuit a été très tendue à
l'occasion de l'examen du projet de loi
de programmation budgétaire l'opposition
à détricoter en fait le texte dans un
hémicycle surchauffé vous n'avez pas
monsieur le ministre
à traiter les députés d'irresponsables
comme vous le faites
par choc contre pare-choc la patience
des automobilistes est mise à rude
épreuve
c'est insupportable c'est insupportable
nouvelle scène de violence seulement
quelques minutes plus tard dans cette
cité de Créteil des jeunes ont mis en
place une station essence clandestine
tout au long de la journée il remplisse
les réservoirs des habitants des
communes aux alentours je suis
extrêmement choqué d'entendre le
président de la République expliquer que
ça n'est pas de sa prérogative que de
gérer de tels blocages on est un peu le
sentiment qu'Emmanuel Macron et
démissionnaire qu'il ne s'intéresse plus
à la vie quotidienne des Français sur
place les forces de l'ordre découvrent
des entonnoirs des bidons et des
bouteilles vides
mais aucune trace de carburant tout le
stock semble avoir été écoulé l'impact
de ce conflit social est devenu nous en
avons conscience insupportable pour de
trop nombreux Français certains sont
empêchés d'aller travailler d'amener
leurs enfants à l'école de faire leurs
courses
plein d'essence à Perpignan madame cela
dégénère en à peine quelques secondes
les insultes pleuvent
un agent tente bien de calmer la
situation en vain la femme est poussée
violemment contre le camion la France
est dans une situation depuis 10 ans de
décadence madame Ferrari de décadence la
sécurité n'est plus assurée la
circulation des habitants n'est plus
assurés aujourd'hui on nous explique à
en France qui est en train de se tirer
des images largement relayées sur les
réseaux sociaux difficile souvent de
savoir l'origine exacte du conflit
mais une certitude la pénurie d'essence
tape sur les nerfs des usagers comment
voulez-vous faire comprendre à les
salariés de Total qui demandent une
valorisation de 10% 7% pour l'inflation
3% pour les profils d'entreprise que
leur patron monsieur pouyanet a augmenté
de 52% son salaire en 2021 pour
atteindre 500.000 euros par mois voilà
ce qui est injuste et vous ne le
combattez pas vous êtes faible avec
l'effort et fort avec les faibles
pourquoi le gouvernement n'a pas agi
avant et qui laisse pourrir la situation
aujourd'hui voire même qui jette de
l'huile sur le feu en faisant des
réquisitions qui vont qui vont plus
susciter de la colère plutôt chez les
grévistes plutôt que de permettre de
réels discussions négociations
nous sommes absolument opposés à ceux
qui en train de faire le gouvernement
c'est-à-dire faire peser sur vous la
menace de la réquisition parce qu'on a
bien compris qu'avec ce gouvernement
c'était constamment la caresse pour les
puissants et la matraque la réquisition
et la répression pour le peuple on dit
depuis maintenant des années que les
mouvements sociaux ne servent à rien
mais là on s'aperçoit que ça sert à
quelque chose moi j'espère que ce sera
l'étincelle qui déclenchera un mouvement
de grève générale la Russie est-elle
devenue un état terroriste
je ne veux pas rentrer dans ces
qualifications d'abord parce qu'ils ont
peu de conséquences peut-être un
tournant en Iran où les travailleurs du
secteur industriel en particulier des
raffineries de pétrole rejoignent le
mouvement de contestation moi je parle
de crimes de guerre qui aujourd'hui
laisse des traces et d'ailleurs pour
lesquelles nous aidons les Ukrainiens à
travailler nous avons dépêché des
magistrats des gendarmes mais je suis
toujours très prudent c'est la justice
internationale qui doit ensuite
qualifier les qualifier les choses il y
a un état qui a déclaré la guerre et
c'est déjà si je puis dire bien
suffisant le secteur de la pétrochimie
est un pilier de l'économie iranienne
son entrée en grève en 1978 lors de la
Révolution avec précipité la chute du
régime